les cherry dans ce qu'il fallait pas
louper je voulais vous montrer le truc
le plus important c'est qu'ils me klum
alors king l'eau c'est une star de télé
réalité voilà hecking l'ol était en
tunisie et elle a poussé deux coups de
gueule et il ya même des mecs qui n'ont
répondu j'espère qu'on a la vidéo de moi
mais dénis qui est énorme mais regardez
la vidéo de king l'eau c'est la vidéo
qui a été le plus vu hier à la fait une
vidéo sur un star regarder d'abord la
première pour moi c'était le fou rire de
m'asseoir et c'est parti si kim gauche
d'allant je la lance moi même je la
lance gilles a annoncé moi-même regardez
je suis à lens moi même je lance même
les vidéos on réapprenne on s'est
beaucoup la population
[Musique]
cette idée de venir ici prendre le vol
easy vizada plan pas d'atouts qui
prévoit la panne de ping pong en même
temps je comprends pas pourquoi ya pas
de l'avion militaire qui l'ont rapatrié
au fait c'est rigolo de minutes mais
c'est pas notre pays this périchole pas
ici c'est la dictature en fait on
retourne à la normale
la patrie mobilité il fait quoi macro
frappé le la du plô qu'elle avait fait
le plein
alors voilà alors cette vidéo c'est une
dar k internationale alors ça c'est
énorme tu l'as vu j'ai vu il ya la
deuxième après que la ride voilà la
première est totalement ahurissante
alors c'est vraiment la personne il faut
le prendre par le bourg quand même parce
que sinon c'est pas possible
elle est la balle est perdue elle cria
macron elle vit elle dit des choses pas
du tout sympa sur la tunisie quand même
qu'ils m'ont pas du tout dit elle dit
que c'est une dictature alors tunisie
voilà donc ça alors qu'il ya eu des
élections démocratiques donc on se
permet pas ça et puis c'est vraiment
l'égoïsme de la star de télé réalité qui
est perdu et qui lance un cri d'alarmé
totalement délirant je préfère y voir de
l'humour parce que sinon c'est pas
possible alors kim goze qu'il faut
savoir c'est que bon elle s'est fait
défoncer sur les gharbaouis donc
forcément elle a fait une deuxième vidéo
après et la deuxième vidéo est encore
plus dark a encore plus drôle
regardez c'est quoi cette polémique ce
rhum le mot dictature que j'aurais dit
alors écoutez moi bien j'étais en stress
après donc j'ai même pas ce que c'est
une dictature donc si vous allez tous
partez vous savez ce que vous disais ok
moi c'est bon j'étais en stress je
pleure parce que je suis bloqué dans un
pays que je m'y attendais pas en fait
donc il faut se détendre en fait
le mot dictature c'est bon il est dit
comme ça c'est pas la fin du monde de
veto le mot dictature c'est bon il est
dit comme ça c'est pas la fin du monde
c'est même pas parce qu'elle a parlé de
dictature à fall harper vidéo donc à la
niche chez même parce que c'est pourquoi
tu dis ça c'est magic mathieu n'est pas
là-dessus bio tu connais ben oui oui kim
boulot mais moi j'ai beaucoup
d'affection pour eux mais on faisait
penser à magali berda aussi vendredi ont
fait les missions qu'on adore mais oui
et les partir le vendredi après midi au
maroc et elle gueule parce que l'avion
est annulé mais elles sont mignonnes
mais c'est du bon sens on avait tous
annulés avant on sait que quand et des
périodes comme ça il faut pas partir et
c'est pas ton de contracter la maladie
c'est de ne pas pouvoir revenir en ville
d'art et bah ouais enfin quand même
c'est du bon sens alors dgac